MALKIN, DAN WON BEGIN OH,
CHARLIE KIRK AND MORE.
POLITICIANS ARE ELECTED TO
REPRESENT US.
HERE HERE TO PUT OUR INTERESTS
OVER POLITICAL INTERESTS.
REFUSAL TO WORK TOWARDS
COMPROMISE IS PUTTING POLITICS
OVER PEOPLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE VIRTUALLY EVERY DAY
WAITING AND WORK, AND TRYING TO
MAKE A DEAL.
BEND AND COMPROMISING AND TRYING
TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
THEY NOT ONLY DISRESPECT HIM.
THEY SOMETIMES DON'T EVEN SHOW
UP.
THEY REFUSED HIS EVERY OVERTURE,
PUTTING A STAKE IN THE GROUND,
PROVING THAT POLITICS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN PUTTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK.
AS 800,000 EMPLOYEES FACE THE
LOVES A SECOND PAYCHECK THIS
TUESDAY, THE DEMOCRATS DISREGARD
THEIR DISTRESS BY NOT
NEGOTIATING THE PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
BUT IT'S EVEN BIGGER.
THEY REFUELS TO NEGOTIATE FOR
PEOPLE WHO LIVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
THEY DON'T CONSIDER AMERICANS
WHOSE LIVES, SAFETY, ECONOMY,
AND SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES ARE
DRAINED BY THESE UNINVITED
ILLEGALS.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT OFFERED YET
ANOTHER COMPROMISE TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT.
THERE WILL BE NO CONCRETE WALL.
ONLY STEEL SLAT BARRIERS.
$5.7 BILLION FOR IT.
$805 MILLION FOR DRUG DETECTION
TECHNOLOGY.
$800 MILLION FOR HUMAN TEAR WHY
ASSISTANCE.
ALMOST 3,000 NEW BORDER AGENTS.
AND 75 NEW IMMIGRATION JUDGES.
THE PRESIDENT DESCRIBED IN CLEAR
AND DIRECT LANGUAGE THE HUMAN
CRISES RANGING FROM 300 OF OUR
CHILDREN DYING EVERY WEEK FROM
HEROIN.
90% OF WHICH COMES TO THOSE
POOREST MEXICAN BORDERS.
NOW YOUNG PEOPLE CAN SEEK ASYLUM
IN THEIR COUNTRY WITHOUT
TRAVELING WITH THOSE DANGEROUS
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS AND COYOTES.
HE TALKED ABOUT WHAM OF US IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT ALREADY KNOW.
PARENTS GIVE THEIR DAUGHTERS
BIRTH CONTROL PILLS, KNOWING
FULL WELL THEIR DAUGHTERS WILL
BE RAPED ALONG THIS DANGEROUS
JOURNEY.
AND THE KNEE-JERK REACTIONS ARE
IN.
NANCY PELOSI CALLS THE
PRESIDENT'S PROPOSALS
UNACCEPTABLE AND SAID WHAT'S
ORIGINAL IN HIS PROPOSAL IS NOT
GOOD, AND WHAT'S GOOD IN HIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT ORIGINAL.
CHUCK SCHUMER, HE CALLED IT
ONE-SIDED AND INEFFECTIVE.
NO SURPRISE.
DEMOCRATS, DEMON RATS, ARE DUG
INTO THE THEATER OF LIES AND
HATE.
CASTING DONALD TRUMP AS EVIL,
WHILE CASTING THEMSELVES AS
ANGELS SUPPORTED BY A MAINSTREAM
MEDIA INTENT ON PUBLISHING ANY
ANTI-TRUMP STORY, HOWEVER
BASELESS OR ABSURD.
JOURNALISTIC STANDARDS BE
DAMMED.
THE THEATER WAS BROUGHT TO THE
ABSURD WHEN NANCY PELOSI SENT A
LETTER TO THE PRESIDENT SAYING
IT WAS TOO DANGEROUS FOR HIM TO
YOU GIVE THE STATE OF THE UNION
SPEECH.
SAYING SHE DIDN'T WANTS HIM
TELLING HIS LIES AND DISTORTIONS
IN THE HOUSE.
A TYPICAL EXAMPLE BY THE WAY OF
WHAT THE LEFT IS DOING IN
GENERAL.
SHUT DOWN THE VOICE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
SHUT DOWN LAW AND ORDER.
SHUT DOWN SECURITY AT OUR
BORDER.
TURNS OUT, NANCY, YOU NEVER EVEN
SPOKE TO SECURITY.
IN FACT EVERY DAY CONGRESS IS IN
SESSION NOBODY HAS BEEN SHUT
DOWN FROM LACK OF SECURITY.
ADMIT IT, YOU MADE IT UP TO SHUT
THEM DOWN.
BUT NEVER IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
GREAT NATION HAS A SPEAKER
REFUSED THE PRESIDENT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE THE STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS.
AND OF COURSE, NOT ONE TO BE
COWED.
THE PRESIDENT PULLS YOU OFF A
GOVERNMENT BUS 30 MINUTES BEFORE
YOUR TRIP TO EUROPE.
NANCY, WHAT THE HELL WERE YOU
DOING BOARDING A BUS WITH YOUR
DEMOCRAT CRONIES ON THE WAY TO
BRUSSELS TO MEET WITH NATO
LEADERS?
THERE IS A PARTIAL GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
WE DON'T NEED YOU IN BRUSSELS.
HOW DO YOU NEGOTIATE YOUR WAY
OUT OF A STALEMATE WHILE ON A
7-DAY EUROPEAN EXCURSION THAT WE
THE TAXPAYERS PAY FOR.
YOU HAVE GOT TO CHUTZPAH, LADY.
WHAT WERE YOU GOING TO DO.
HAVE A FEW PARTIES ON OUR DIME.
AND THEN YOU AND YOUR BAND OF
FRIENDLIES, OFF THEN TO
AFGHANISTAN TO FIND OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON FROM THE TROOPS ON THE
GROUND.
REALLY?
YOU THINK SOME SOLDIER IS GOING
TO SAUNTER UP AND WHISPER IN
YOUR EAR TO GIVE YOU THE REAL
SCOOP WHEN HIS BOSSES AT THE
PENTAGON WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO SO
IN WASHINGTON?
OR IS IT YOU THINK THE TROOPS
ARE DYING TO SEE YOU.
SEND THEM A VIDEO, NANCY, AND
THANK THEM.
AND BY THE WAY.
IS THIS HOW YOU REINFORCE YOUR
POWER BASE?
ARE YOU THE CAREER JUNKET
ORGANIZER?
BUT THEN YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN ONE
TO SACRIFICE.
HOW ABOUT INSTEAD OF THE TRIPS
YOU ESCROW THAT MONEY FOR
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES.
WHAT'S THAT?
YOU WOULD RATHER NOT BECAUSE
POLLING BLAMES TRUMP FOR THE
SHUTDOWN AND YOU ARE GOOD WITH
THAT.
BY THE WAY, NANCY, SO IS HE.
HE'S WEARING HIS BIG BOY PANTS
AND HE OFFERED TO TAKE THE
BURDEN JUST TO GET IT DONE.
HOW ABOUT SINCE YOU ARE IN
CHARGE OF ALL SPENDING BILLS,
NANCY, YOU FOREGO YOUR CHECK
UNTIL THIS IS OVER.
MAN UP LIKE THE FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES GOING THROUGH THE
SHUTDOWN.
DONATE CONGRESSIONAL SALARIES TO
THOSE WHO WON'T GET ONE.
AFTER ALL, FOR A START, YOU AND
YOUR HUSBAND ARE WORTH OVER $100
MILLION.
HOW DID YOU MAKE THAT MONEY,
NANCY?
HOW LONG HAS IT BEEN SINCE YOU
HAVE BEEN IN CONGRESS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP ISN'T TAKING A
CHECK.
HE DONATED HIS SALARY SINCE DAY
ONE TO A NUMBER OF FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
AND NANCY, THIS IS JUST THE TWO
OF US TALKING, ADMIT IT, YOUR
BIG DONORS IN CALIFORNIA WANT
ILLEGALS TO PICK GRAPES.
EVEN CESAR CHAVEZ, YOU ARE OLD
ENOUGH TO REMEMBER HIM, FOUGHT
TOOTH AND NAIL TO STOP ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, TO PROTECTS LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
AND THE FARM WORKERS.
IT'S ALL THEATER, FOLKS.
THE PRESIDENT THEY SAY IS A FEAR
MONGER.
THIS IS A MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
SAY THAT TO THE FACE OF AN ANGEL
MOM WHOSE CHILD WAS MURDER AND
MASS CURLED BY AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT.
YOU HAVE KIDS, NANCY?
YOU DO, DON'T YOU?
WHY DID YOU APPROVE SECURING
THE -- THE BORDER LIKE SO MANY
OF YOUR DEMOCRAT CRONIES IN 2006
AND '13 UNDER THE SECURE FENCE
ACT, BUT NOT THIS.
THE OBVIOUS ANSWER BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP WANTS IT.
INSTEAD YOUR PATH IS TO
DISRESPECT AMERICANS.
INSTEAD RESPECT THOSE WHO
VIOLATE OUR LAWS.
WHILE YOU AND YOUR ILK PRAISE
PICTURES OF FURLOUGHED FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES WHEN YOU WON'T MEET
WITH THE ANGEL MOMS WHO COME TO
OUR OFFICE WITH PICTURES OF
AMERICAN CHILDREN KILLED BY
ILLEGALS.
LET ME SEE IF I UNDERSTAND THIS.
AN AMERICAN MOTHER SHOWS A
PICTURE OFFED A CHILD MURDERED
BY AN ILLEGAL.
AND CHUCK SCHUMER AND HIS GANG
COME OUT AND SHOW PICTURES OF
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES.
IS THERE A MORAL EQUIVALENTSSY?
ARE YOU WORKING FOR AMERICANS
OR ILLEGALS?
OR IS IT THAT YOU JUST DON'T
GIVE A DAMN.
YOU VACATION IN HAWAII.
YOUR BUDDIES VACATION WITH
LOBBYISTS IN PUERTO RICO DURING
THE SHUTDOWN.
AND YOU PLAN A JAUNT TO EUROPE
WHILE FEDERAL EMPLOYEES ARE
TRYING TO SAVE EVERY DOLLAR TO
BUY GROCERIES.
ADMIT IT, YOU DON'T GIVE A DAMN.
AND YOU ARE A HYPOCRITE WITH A
POLITICAL OPERATIVE.
YOUR MANTRA, DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
TO HELL WITH THE TAX PAYING
HARD-WORKING AMERICANS.
LET THEM EAT CAKE.
I HAVE GOT A JUNKET TO GO ON.
AN EGO TO ASSUAGE.
AN ELECTORATE TO IGNORE.
NANCY, IF YOU ARE TOO AFRAID TO
TAKE A COMMERCIAL FLIGHT, THERE
ARE ALTERNATE WAYS TO FLY.